going back to planting these seeds your
your through connections your reaching
out to these people is it via email via
LinkedIn are you calling how are you
doing that what I like to try and do is
I like to have someone else approach
managers and agents for me so I will
talk to potentially some of the talent
that we had I'm killing with some Jones
or I will talk to some of the
connections that I have from when I was
working at innovative the assistants
that I worked alongside now that are you
know agents or junior agents or
development execs or working in some
creative capacity in the industry and
see if they can you know call in the
favor for me I mean the thing is I have
developed quite a few relationships so
what I try to rely on is people that
actually want to help me so if they read
a script of mine and it's the worst
thing they've ever read then it's not a
fit for them to try and help me and take
it to anyone but if they read it in it
and it speaks to them for some reason
and they want to take it out or they
want to talk to someone about it for me
I you know that's primarily how I
approach the situation I just think that
having worked in the agencies receiving
an email if you're an assistant or
you're an agent you're so busy with
other projects that email is most likely
going to end up in the trash and I'm not
saying that it should be that way and
it's too bad that it is that way but
that's just that's just the way that it
is it's the same with cold calling or a
phone call if you can have someone call
on your behalf if you know someone who's
representative that boutique agency or
that top agency and they can make a call
on your behalf and get the ball rolling
that's usually the best way to do it so
I think you'll find a lot more success
when you can draw those connections so
it sounds like when you do have
something in the works that's when you
start planting these seeds in terms of
reaching out and knowing that it may be
a no or just a maybe or we'll look into
it but then once they see the final
results of that and know that you
we trusted to deliver then that's when
stuff starts happening so that people
should be planning that well let me give
you an example so when I was working at
innovative I Joel Moore had just come
off the success of dodgeball
and so everyone there at the agency was
courting him they wanted to give him
different projects to go out on and he
was in the office all the time and one
day I ran into him and I said I have
this script that I'm writing and I think
you would be absolutely perfect for one
of the roles that role ended up going to
Jon Heder when we finally got it made
but you know that's probably a green
thing to do I was an assistant at the
time I don't know that I'd recommend
that to people but Joel being the
brilliant and kind person that he is
you know indulge me and said great when
you have it send it to me I'll read it
I'll read anything that you send me
and once I left the agencies and I was
taking the time to finish this
particular project killing with some
Jones in the script I sent it to him and
because of that small interaction that
we had you know all those years earlier
and luckily he read it and he really
enjoyed it I mean he called me a day
after I sent it to him and wanted to
direct it and star in it and produce it
which of course I'm not gonna say no
because anyone at that point that's
bringing themselves on especially
someone with the credits such as Joel
has you know that's that's a great
opportunity for me so based on that that
connection alone we were able to make it
to make the film now that's rare though
I think that like I said when I was
getting at before those moments are few
and far between I think if you're
working in an agency capacity and talent
comes in and you can talk with them
great do it but a lot of times if you
were to see an agent or see an actor on
the outside world and you started
pitching them your idea or your project
it's just not not going to happen
it's the same with représente
you know the more people you can have in
your corner helping you and talking with
people on your behalf especially people
who have established themselves at that
point that's going to be the most
helpful
you